T
9:00.
>> Sean: THINK HE WAS ALWAYS.
WE APPRECIATE IT AND WELCOME TO
"HANNITY."
>> AMERICA HELD HOSTAGE,
ABANDONED BEHIND ENEMY LINES.
>> Sean: THINK OF IT, 45 DAYS.
45 DAYS SINCE HUNDREDS AND
HUNDREDS OF AMERICANS AND THEIR
FAMILIES ABANDONED BEHIND ENEMY
LINES, 45 DAYS SINCE THOUSANDS
OF GREEN CARD HOLDERS, APEL
ELIGIBLE TO BE IN THIS COUNTRY
LEGALLY, WERE ABANDONED.
45 DAYS SINCE THOUSANDS OF SIV
HOLDERS AND THEIR FAMILIES WERE
ABANDONED AND OUR AFGHAN ALLIES,
AND 40 DAYS SINCE JOE BIDEN LIED
TO THE ENTIRE WORLD AND PROMISED
TO STAY IN AFGHANISTAN UNTIL
EVERY SINGLE U.S. CITIZEN WAS
SAFELY OUT OF THE COUNTRY.
SADLY, THAT WASN'T JOE BIDEN'S
ONLY BLATANT LIE, BECAUSE TODAY
ON CAPITOL HILL, BIDEN'S TOP
MILITARY ADVISORS, THEY
CONTRADICTED HIM OVER AND OVER
AGAIN.
NOW, IN A MOMENT, WE ARE GOING
TO DISCUSS GENERAL MILLEY'S
LEAKING, THE ALLEGATIONS THAT
SOME ARE EVEN DESCRIBING AS HIGH
AS TREASON LEVELED AGAINST HIM.
FIRST WE GO TO OUR SO-CALLED
COMMANDER IN CHIEF.
REMEMBER AUGUST THE 19TH?
HE TOLD FELLOW DEMOCRATIC
SOCIALIST GEORGE STEPHANOPOULOS
OVER AT ABC THAT HIS MILITARY
ADVISORS DID NOT RECOMMEND A
CONTINUED U.S. MILITARY PRESENCE
IN AFGHANISTAN.
THIS IS WHAT JOE SAID, LISTEN.
>> TOP MILITARY VISORS WARNED
AGAINST THIS TIMELINE, THEY
WANTED YOU TO KEEP ABOUT 2500
TUBES.
'S >> President Biden: NO THEY
DIDN'T.
>> THEY DIDN'T TELL YOU THEY
WANTED TROOPS TO STAY?
>> President Biden: NOT IN
TERMS OF WHETHER WE WERE GOING
TO GET OUT IN A TIME FRAME ALL
TROOPS.
THEY DIDN'T ARGUE AGAINST THAT.
>> YOUR MILITARY ADVISORS DID
NOT TELL YOU KNOW, WE SHOULD
JUST KEEP 2500 TROOPS, IT'S BEEN
A STABLE SITUATION FOR THE LAST
COUPLE YEARS, WE CAN DO THAT, WE
CAN CONTINUE TO DO THAT?
>> President Biden: NO, NO ONE
SAID THAT TO ME THAT I CAN
RECALL.
>> Sean: NO ONE SAID THAT TO
ME THAT I CAN RECALL.
ACCORDING TO EVERYONE THAT
TESTIFIED TO THEM CAPITOL HILL
UNDER OATH, THEY SAY JOE BIDEN
WAS LYING.
THEY ALL TOLD HIM 2500 SHOULD
STAY.
LISTEN.
>> I WON'T SHARE MY PERSONAL
RECOMMENDATION TO THE PRESIDENT
BUT I WILL GIVE YOU MY HONEST
OPINION IN MY HONEST OPINION AND
VIEW SHAPED MY WRECK MENTATION.
I RECOMMENDED THAT WE MAINTAIN
2500 TROOPS IN AFGHANISTAN.
>> IT YOUR TESTIMONY THAT YOU
RECOMMENDED 2500 TROOPS
APPROXIMATELY STAY IN
AFGHANISTAN?
>> AS I'VE SAID MANY TIMES
BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE AND -- I
CAN TELL YOU MY PERSONAL OPINION
AND MY ASSESSMENT IF YOU WANT.
>> YES PLEASE.
>> YES, MY ASSESSMENT WAS BACK
IN THE FALL OF APOSTOLATE 20 AND
MADE CONSISTENT THROUGHOUT THAT
WE SHOULD KEEP A STEADY STATE OF
2500, COULD BOUNCE UP TO 3500.
>> Sean: I DON'T SHOW THE
PERSONAL OPINIONS I HAVE WITH
THE PRESIDENT, AND LESS OF
COURSE HER NAME IS BOB WOODWARD
OR ROB COSTA.
BY THE WAY, JEN PSAKI, CARE TO
CIRCLE BACK AND EXPLAIN THIS?
WAS JOE BIDEN LYING?
WERE YOU LYING?
WE DON'T NEED COVID TEST BECAUSE
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO BE HERE
VERY LONG.
YOU'RE TELLING A LOT OF LIES IN
THAT WHITE HOUSE.
>> THE PRESENCE AT HIS MILITARY
COMMANDERS WERE SPLIT.
WE NOW KNOW THE CHAIRMAN JOINT
CHIEF OF STAFF GENERAL MILLEY --
GENERAL McKENZIE AND THE
COMMANDER ON THE GROUND,
GENERAL MILLER, ALL RECOMMENDED
TO KEEP 2500 TROOPS.
SO WHO IN HIS MILITARY ADVISORS
TOLD HIM IT WOULD BE FINDABLE
EVERY BUDDY OUT?
>> Secretary Psaki: I'M NOT
GOING TO GET INTO SPECIFIC
DETAILS OF WHO RECOMMENDED WHAT.
>> YOU ARE SAYING HERE THAT
MILITARY ADVISORS TO THE
PRESIDENT SAID IT WAS OKAY TO
PULL ALL THE TROOPS OUT.
>> Secretary Psaki: THAT'S NOT
WHAT I SAID.
>> THE PRESIDENT PULLED ALL U.S.
TROOPS ARE.
YOU ARE SAYING THERE WERE
MILITARY COMMANDERS WHO ADVISED
HIM THAT THAT WAS A GOOD IDEA TO
PULL ALL AMERICAN TROOPS OUT AND
THAT GENERAL MILLEY,
GENERAL McKENZIE,
GENERAL MILLER, THEY SAID
SOMETHING ELSE, BUT THE
PRESIDENT'S TOP MILITARY VISORS,
OTHERS WE WON'T NAME, TOLD HIM
SURE, WE CAN PULL EVERYONE OUT?
>> Secretary Psaki: THAT'S NOT
HOW THESE CONVERSATIONS GO.
IT'S A RISK ASSESSMENT.
>> Sean: JOE BIDEN LIED AND
SHE IS SPINNING LIKE A TOP.
IN OTHER WORDS, JOE BIDEN WENT
AGAINST THE ADVICE AND COUNSEL
OF HIS TOP MILITARY ADVISORS AND
YET, HE OUTRIGHT LIED ABOUT IT.
BUT THAT WASN'T JOE'S ONLY LIGHT
BECAUSE WE LEARNED A LOT TODAY.
WE LEARNED THAT JOE BIDEN WAS
LESS THAN TRUTHFUL, IN OTHER
WORDS LYING, ABOUT OUR SO-CALLED
OVER THE HORIZON ANTI-TERROR
CAPABILITIES IN A SPEECH ON
AUGUST 31ST.
JOE BREAKING THE UNITED STATES
DOES NOT NEED THE TROOPS ON THE
GROUND IN AFGHANISTAN IN ORDER
TO MAINTAIN THE FIGHT AGAINST
TERRORISTS AND KEEP OUR COUNTRY
SAFE AND THAT OUR CREDIBILITY
AROUND THE WORLD REMAINS TOTALLY
PRISTINE.
THAT IS A CLAIM THAT BIDEN'S TOP
GENERALS CLEARLY DISPUTE.
LOOK FOR YOURSELF.
>> OUR CREDIBILITY HAS BEEN
GRAVELY DAMAGED, HAS IT NOT,
GENERAL MILLEY?
>> I THINK THAT OUR CREDIBILITY
WITH ALLIES AND PARTNERS AROUND
THE WORLD AND WITH ADVERSARIES
IS BEING INTENSELY REVIEWED BY
THEM TO SEE WHICH WAY THIS IS
GOING TO GO, AND I THINK THE
DAMAGE IS ONE WORD THAT COULD BE
USED, YES.
>> IS THE WAR ON TERROR OVER?
GENERAL MILLEY?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
>> GENERAL McKENZIE?
>> THE WAR ON TERROR IS NOT OVER
IN THE WAR IN AFGHANISTAN IS NOT
OVER EITHER.
>> HAS THE EXIT FROM AFGHANISTAN
MADE THE WAR MORE CHALLENGING
FOR US OR LESS CHALLENGING?
WITH RESPECT TO CONTINUING TO
TRY AND PROTECT THE HOMELAND IN
U.S. INTERESTS ABROAD.
>> SENATOR, IT'S MADE IT MORE
CHALLENGING.
>> GENERAL MILLEY, DO YOU AGREE?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> Sean: THE WAR'S NOT OVER.
JOE SAID THAT HE'S TURNED THE
PAGE AND THAT IS DEALING WITH A
VERY PROFESSIONAL BUSINESSLIKE
TALIBAN THAT ARE NOW KILLING
PEOPLE AND TORTURING WOMEN AND
TAKING AWAY ALL OF THEIR RIGHTS.
SO JOE BIDEN WAS REPEATEDLY TOLD
THAT OUR OVER THE HORIZON
CAPABILITIES WERE NOT
SUFFICIENT.
ANOTHER LIE.
HE WAS TOLD AND HE KNEW THAT
AFGHANISTAN WOULD COLLAPSE
WITHOUT U.S. SUPPORT.
HE KNEW ABANDONING BAGRAM
AIRBASE IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
NIGHT WOULD LEAVE AMERICANS
VIRTUALLY DEFENSELESS.
HE KNEW THE TALIBAN WAS RAPIDLY
ADVANCING THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY.
THE WHOLE WORLD KNEW IT.
IF THEY KNEW IT IN MARCH, APRIL,
MAY, JUNE, AND JULY, AND HE
STILL BRAGGING ABOUT THE
TRAINING IN THE AFGHAN MILITARY
THAT WAS COLLAPSING BEFORE THE
WORLD 'ASSIZE.
JOE BIDEN CONTINUED TO RUSH
THROUGH HIS BOTCHED AND VERY
PREVENTABLE WITHDRAWAL ANYWAY
BECAUSE JOE WANTED TO BRAG THAT
HE SUCCESSFULLY ENDED AMERICA'S
LONGEST WAR.
AND THEN PREDICTABLY, WHEN
EVERYTHING WENT SOUTH, HE JUST
LIED ABOUT ALL OF IT, WHICH
PRETTY MUCH SUMS UP THE
PLAGIARIST JOE BIDEN'S ENTIRE
CAREER.
HE'S BEEN AND REMAINS A
SPINELESS COWARD, ZERO
INTEGRITY, AND HE LIVES WITH
ABANDON, AND SPEAKING OF
INTEGRITY, THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
JOINT CHIEFS, WELL,
GENERAL MILLEY IS ALSO SEEMINGLY
LACKING.
THIS NEW BOOK FROM WOODWARD AND
ROBERT COSTA IS ALL ABOUT ALL
BUT ACCUSING MILLEY, AT LEAST IN
THE DEFINITION OF MANY, OF
BETRAYING THIS COUNTRY, EVEN
THOUGH THEY ARE NOW DEFENDING
MILLEY, MEANING THE AUTHORS,
THEY WOULD BURN A LEAKING SOURCE
LIKE A CHAIRMAN OF THE JOINT
CHIEFS?
I DON'T THINK THEY WOULD WANT TO
BURN THAT SO QUICKLY, BUT
ACCORDING TO THE ALLEGATIONS IN
MILLEY EVEN TRIED TO DEFEND THEM
TODAY, MILLEY PROMISED COMMUNIST
CHINA, OUR SWORN ENEMY, A
HOSTILE REGIME IN TWO SECRET
PHONE CALLS HE WOULD GIVE THEM A
HEADS UP IF THEN PRESIDENT TRUMP
DECIDED TO ATTACK.
OF THE WAY I READ THE
CONSTITUTION, THE COMMANDER IN
CHIEF, THAT WOULD BE THE DULY
ELECTED PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
UNDER OATH, POLICE RESPONSE WAS
AT BEST SHIFTY, ALTHOUGH AT
ONE POINT HE JUST PRETTY MUCH
OUTRIGHT ADMITS THAT YEAH, HE
WOULD GIVE THEM A HEADS UP.
YOU DECIDE.
>> YOU ARE QUOTED IN THE
WOODWARD BOOK AS TELLING THE TOP
CHINESE COMMUNIST MILITARY
COMMANDER "IF WE ARE GOING TO
ATTACK, I'M GOING TO CALL YOU
AHEAD OF TIME."
IS THAT TRUE, GENERAL MILLEY?
>> LET ME TELL YOU WHAT I
ACTUALLY SAID.
>> SO THAT'S NOT TRUE.
I HOPE THAT'S NOT TRUE.
>> LET ME TELL YOU WHAT I
ACTUALLY SAID, SENATOR.
WHAT I SAID, IF THERE'S GOING TO
BE A WAR, IF IT'S GOING TO BE AN
ATTACK, THERE'S GOING TO BE A
LOT OF CALLS AND TENSION AHEAD
OF TIME.
YOU'RE GOING TO THE CALLS --
>> [INDISCERNIBLE]
PRESIDENT TRUMP WOULD NOT
ATTACKED, THAT IS YOUR TESTIMONY
THIS MORNING.
>> THAT IS TRUE.
AND I WAS COMMUNICATING TO MY
CHINESE COUNTERPART ON
INSTRUCTIONS, BY THE WAY, TO
DE-ESCALATE THE SITUATION.
AND I TOLD HIM IF THERE WAS
GOING TO BE AN ATTACK, THERE
WILL BE PLENTY OF COMMUNICATIONS
GOING BACK AND FORTH, THEIR
INTEL SYSTEMS ARE GOING TO PICK
IT UP, I SAID I WILL PROBABLY
CALL YOU, EVERYBODY WILL BE
CALLING YOU.
>> Sean: I WILL PROBABLY CALL
YOU AND TELL YOU THE ATTACK IS
COMING.
WELL, THAT WOULD BE AN
ADMISSION.
THAT WOULD BE BECAUSE FOR
IMMEDIATE DISMISSAL.
NOW, WOODWARD AND COSTA PROBABLY
TAPED HIM, SO HE KNEW HE
COULDN'T REALLY OUTRIGHT LIE,
MAYBE IT'S TIME TO RELEASE THOSE
TAPES TO CONGRESS.
ONE THING THAT MILLEY DID FULLY
ADMIT TO, HE GOSSIPS LIKE A MEAN
GIRL IN HIGH SCHOOL, TO USE A
PHRASE, TO EVERY SINGLE REPORTER
IN TOWN EVEN THOUGH HE SAYS I
DON'T DISCLOSE THE CONVERSATIONS
I HAVE WITH THE PRESIDENT.
IN LESSER NAME IS WOODWARD
ACOSTA, THEN YOU TELL THEM
EVERYTHING.
LISTEN.
>> GENERAL MILLEY, YES OR NO TO
THIS, DID YOU TALK TO BOB
WOODWARD OR ROBERT COSTA FOR
THEIR BOOK "PERIL"?
>> WOODWARD YES, COSTA NO.
>> DID YOU TALK TO KAREN LEONE
AND PHILIP RUCKER FOR THEIR
BOOK?
>> YES.
>> DID YOU TALK TO MICHAEL
VENTER FOR HIS BOOK, FRANKLY WE
DID WIN THIS ELECTION, THE STORY
OF HOW TRUMP LOST?
>> YES.
>> WHY WOULD HE WAS A SITTING
CHAIRMAN OF THE JOINT CHIEFS OF
STAFF TALK TO A REPORT OF ITS
WRITING A BOOK ABOUT A PRIOR
ADMINISTRATION?
WHY WOULD THAT BE PART OF YOUR
JOB DESCRIPTION?
>> WELL, SENATOR BLACKBURN SAID
EARLIER, I DEAL WITH THE MEDIA
ROUTINELY, TWO OR THREE OR FOUR
TIMES A WEEK I'M TALKING TO THE
MEDIA.
>> Sean: THIS WOULD BE CALLED
LEAKING AND THIS WOULD BE CALLED
VIEWING PRIVATE CONVERSATIONS
WITH YOUR BOSS, HOW PATHETIC.
REMEMBER GENERAL MILLEY IS THE
JOINT CHIEFS OF STAFF, OUR
HIGHEST RANKING MILITARY
OFFICIAL.
WHY WOULD HE BE LEAKING TO ANY
REPORTERS AND GOSSIPING TO
REPORTERS ABOUT HIS BOSS?
HOW EXACTLY IS OUR COUNTRY SAFER
OR MORE SECURE WITH
GENERAL MILLEY LEAKING AND
GOSSIPING ALL OVER TOWN TO EVER
REPORTER THAT HAS A BOOK DEAL?
APPARENTLY HE TALKED TO A LOT OF
THEM.
HOW DOES THAT ADVANCE OUR
NATIONAL SECURITY?
IT DOESN'T.
AFTER TODAY IT IS CLEAR,
GENERAL MILLEY NEEDS TO RESIGN
OR BE FIRED.
HE ABSOLUTELY NEEDS TO BE
INVESTIGATED FOR THE LEAKS, THE
CALLS, WITH CHINA, WHETHER HE
WAS TRYING TO ASSERT THE POWER
OF THE UNITED STATES, WHETHER HE
WAS COORDINATE AND WITH OUR
SWORN ENEMY, WHAT HE HAD IN
TERMS OF CONVERSATIONS WITH
SPEAKER PELOSI